all right it's time for la
vegas now what should you do if you get
into a car accident there are a few
steps you should take directly
afterwards to ensure your safety
and make sure you're getting adequate
compensation i spoke with local attorney
eric palacios earlier today
for some professional tips what would
you say are the biggest mistakes people
make
when it comes to accidents great
question
where to begin people make so many
mistakes right after an accident but
uh the first one we see is they don't
call the police
a lot of times the person that causes
the accident begs them and says please
don't call
the police we'll just fix this between
ourselves uh then the person
doesn't call the police and later uh we
see that the person that caused the
accident
changes their story and now it's uh more
difficult to establish
who's at fault and who caused the
accident and who's liable for it
okay so make sure to call the police
what would you say about insurance
companies
uh insurance companies are going to call
you right away so you have to be very
careful on what you talk to them about
it's okay to talk to them about fixing
your car
but generally we don't advise clients to
talk to the insurance company about how
the accident happened
and especially don't talk to them about
whether you're feeling pain or what
injuries
you think you might be suffering the day
of the accident or immediately after the
accident
a lot of times your injuries don't
manifest themselves you've got
a shock the adrenaline got scared
all that makes your your brain focus on
other things rather than
what your body is feeling and any
injuries you might have
what advice would you give to people who
have an insurance company offer them up
cash
that day never accept this offer don't
sign any documents
this is a practice that a lot of
insurance companies have is they'll run
out to the scene of the accident
and offer you a check right there on the
spot but you still don't know
the extent of your injuries if you're
going to need medical treatment if
you're going to need extended
medical care if you take this check
sign the paperwork you're basically
closing your claim
and your case is over because this
practice
is so dangerous now the
law has changed and if you sign a
document accepting
uh to close your case even if you accept
uh money
the day of the accident or sooner after
without the advisor without
representation from an attorney
you now have the ability to undo that
and
to reestablish your claim but you have
to act quickly
and you have to get the help of an
attorney okay so even if you sign the
contract you're not completely out of
options
yes now uh you have uh an option but
there's a very
narrow window of time where you can undo
this and open your claim again so it's
important that you give us a call right
away
and you all can um not just get
compensation but also
medical treatment help with medical
treatment should you need it right yes
the three main concerns obviously is is
getting your your car repaired that's
how we get to work how to take the kids
to school
that's very important uh secondly is am
i going to miss time off work who's
going to
compensate me for that who's going to
pay my bills while i'm unable to work
and we can help with that as well and
third and most important is
receiving medical treatment with no
upfront cost
doesn't cost you anything out of pocket
until the end of the case
and also our services we don't charge
anything until we win your case at the
end
okay eric well thank you as always for
coming on and
explaining this to us great thanks for
having me
and for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
at
702-444-7777